>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: And I'd like
to welcome you to Immigration
and Children's Literature, the
Role of Heritage and Storytelling.
It's sponsored by the Young Readers
Center and the Center for the Book
at the Library of Congress.
This program is a sequel
to our diversity symposium,
which we hosted last Spring in
which many of you were participants.
We had such a terrific
response, both to the program
and to the utility of the
online webcast that followed
that we've expanded the conversation
to explore the contribution
of diverse cultural
experiences from first
and second generation Americans to
literature for children and youth.
I want to extend our gratitude to
the Virginia Center for the Book
at the Virginia Foundation for the
Humanities and the Maryland Center
for the Book at Maryland Humanities,
for supporting this
program again this year.
Also our colleagues at
the Center for the Book,
most specifically Dr. John Cole
and Bonnie and Guy Lamallanara
and the YRC staff Kaheen Mohammad,
Monica Valentine and to our interns
and volunteers who always
make what we do possible.
This exchange comes at a critical
time in our national conversation
about American and its immigrants.
And thinking about that role,
the role that culture has
in this conversation and literature
in particular, I'd like to go back
to 1947 when Rogers and Hammerstein
premiered South Pacific on Broadway,
based on the book "Tales of the
South Pacific" by James Michener.
The song that stirred
quite a controversy was
"You've got to be carefully taught".
And here quickly is a first stanza.
You've got to be taught
to hate and fear.
from year to year.
It's got to be drummed
in your dear little ear.
You've got to be carefully taught.
Many letters and the papers of
Oscar Hammerstein at the Library
of Congress demonstrated the
polarizing nature of this tune,
very much meant by both Rogers
and Hammerstein to be a comment
on the racial prejudice
of the times.
And by the way the library has the
piano vocal scores of South Pacific
in the performing arts reading
room and the sound recording
of the original Broadway cast in
the recorded sound reference center.
But our conversation today takes a
very different and optimistic turn.
Our premise does include the
value of language and education,
but from a different place, by
sharing values, culture and stories
from the heritage, their
heritage our authors
and illustrator make
positive contributions
to the future of our children.
And we're going to hear about
some examples this afternoon.
Our first author Meg
Medina also serving
as the moderator for the discussion.
Meg has been a collaborator
both last year's symposium
as well as today's program.
And we're so grateful for her
wisdom, creativity and passion
for her profession and
for her compatriots.
Meg is an award winning
Cuban American author
who writes picture books,
middle grade and YA fiction.
She's the 2014 recipient
of Pura Belpre medal
and the 2013 Civil Fiction winner
for her young adult novel Yaqui
Delgado Wants to Kick Your Ass.
Everybody always makes
a noise about that Meg.
And in 2015 her picture
book, Mango Abuela
and Me was a Pura Belpre
Honor medal.
She is also the 2012 Ezra Jack
Keats New Writers medal winner
for her picture book
Tia Isa Wants a Car.
Her other books are The Girl
Who Could Silence the Wind,
a 2012 Bank Street Best Book and
CBI recommended read in the UK.
And Milagros: Girl From Away.
Her newest novel Burn Baby Burn
has earned four star reviews
and is a Junior Library
Guild selection.
Perhaps the most revealing accolade
is her 2014 nomination from CNN
when she was named one of CNN
10 visionary women in America
for her work to support girls,
Latino youth and diversity
in children's literature.
I now turn the program over to Meg,
who will introduce her
colleagues and lead the discussion.
including a 20 minute
Q & A at the end.
At the conclusion of the
program we'll have a book signing
with all of our panelists.
Meg.
[ Applause ]
>> Meg Medina: So I have my phone
up here, not because I'm waiting
for an important call, but
because I talk too much and I want
to make sure that I get everything
in that we have to get in today.
So, good afternoon everybody and
it is such a pleasure to be here
with all of you today at
the Library of Congress,
which I think is easily one of
my favorite places in the world.
Whether I'm touring the beautiful
rooms in the Jefferson Building
or whether I'm here tucked away in
the Madison Building doing research
as I did here for Burn Baby Burn.
It's safe to say that I think the
Library is a place that stands
for our best ideals, about
the written word and the power
of being a literate
and engaged people.
So many, many thanks to Karen
Jaffe and the young leaders center
for this kind invitation.
To me and to all of these authors
and for this wonderful opportunity
to be with all of you today.
So, I have been looking forward
to this afternoon's conversation
about immigration and
children's literature for months.
I am, myself the daughter of Cuban
immigrants, the wife of an immigrant
and a children's book author who
seeks to write about all the places
where childhood culture
and family meet.
It's my life's work really, and it's
a privilege and a joyous work even
when I'm writing about
the harder aspects
of a dual identity and that strain.
I find myself in exceptional
company this afternoon with a group
of talented up and coming authors
who we've invited because they bring
to their work what we decided was
a very nuanced and authentic voice
and because they represent a range
of nations and a variety of points
on a continuum of what we
collectively call immigrants.
Today the goal is to
talk about, to each other
and discover how the immigrant as
an experience shapes us as writers
and why it matters to us
to voice our experience
in works for children.
And of course our hope is that this
conversation offers you a window
inside immigrant children and their
families and a road map for how
to use diverse stories with children
in your personal and
professional lives.
Our hope is that today's
conversation strengthens our
collective commitment to plural
narratives in children's fiction
so that all of us who are American
can feel valued and included.
As ground work some statistics from
the migration policy institute here
in Washington D.C. that
you might find interesting.
As of 2016 the US foreign
born population
and the US foreign children
accounted for 81 million people.
More than a quarter
of our population.
In 2014, 1.3 million
people migrated to the US,
a figure that includes
estimates of the undocumented.
The top countries of origin in
order were India, China, Mexico.
Canada and the Philippines.
And for those of you
who work with children
and families you might
be interested to know
that in 2014 17.5 million
children lived
with at least one parent
who was an immigrant.
And interestingly 88% of children
of immigrant parents are born
in the United States
and are therefore second
generation Americans.
All of those figures
represent a quadruple growth
in the immigrants present
in the US since 1970.
So yes, we are a nation
of immigrants
and our collective identity is
based on the Statue of Liberty.
Given your poor, your tired masses
and all the rest of that inscribed
at the base of the Statue of
Liberty, but as we know especially
in this election year there
is considerable backlash
against the foreign
born in our country.
This native rhetoric is nothing
new sadly; it's what Dr. Alan Krout
of American University refers
to as old wine in new bottles.
Our nation unfortunately
has a history
of native sentiments particularly
in times of economic downturn.
Throughout history we've selected
different groups to target
with suspicions of their
religion, with accusations
that they bring disease or
lawlessness, that they are a threat
to civil order or our
national security.
So think of anti-Catholicism,
which regard to Irish and Germans
in the early 20th century
and the backlash
against Muslim Americans today.
Think of quota systems to limit
the foreign born, and legislations
like the Chinese Exclusion
Act of the 1800's.
Think of internment camps for
Japanese Americans in World War II,
and think today of these
conversations about sparkling walls
that we will build at our borders.
And yet, we are all
here, all Americans,
all trying to find a way forward and
a way to love families and children.
And in this effort we turn as a
people, as we always have I think
to the arts, to help us name the
experience and to build bridges.
So today I'd like to introduce these
wonderful colleagues who will speak
on how immigrant identity
impacts their works for children.
If you are tweeting, parentheses,
you would use the hashtag
please #youngreadersimmigration,
and also tag @librarycongress.
All right.
On the end, Aisha Saeed.
>> Aisha Saeed: Hello.
>> Meg Medina: Is a Pakistani
American author of several works,
including her beautiful debut young
adult novel Written in the Stars,
which came out of England in 2015.
And the upcoming middle grade
novel This Promise I Will Keep,
also Penguin and we
can expect it in 2017.
Her work also has appeared in
anthology such as Love and Shout,
the secret love lives of
American Muslim Women,
that came out soft scull in
2012 and Faithfully Feminist,
which came out White
Cloud Press in 2015.
Aisha is also one of
the founding members
of the non-profit we
need diverse books.
She lives in Atlanta with her
husband and her three sons,
including a little baby,
who was just born this year
and she's represented by Taylor
Martindale of Full Circle Literary.
Beside her, many of you know the
fabulous Wendy Wan-Long Shang.
Her most recent book is the Way
Home Looks Now, which was inspired
by Taiwan's dominance of the
Little League World Series
and her father's experience coaching
baseball in the early 1970's.
Home is a Junior Library
Guild selection and a pick
by book pages best of the year list.
Her debut novel, which is
when I first fell in love
with Wendy was the
Great Wall of Lucy Wu,
which came out of Scholastic
and received the Asian Pacific
American Librarians Association
Children's Literature Award,
as well as recognition
on several state reading lists.
When she is not writing, Wendy
volunteers with her local library
and roots for the Nationals with
her husband and her three children.
Beside her Elizabeth Zunon.
Drawing and painting have always
been among the most important things
to Elizabeth Zunon.
She was born in Albany,
New York and grew
up on the Ivory Coast, West Africa.
Surrounded by the bright,
vibrant colors
of everyday West African
fabrics and tropical vegetation,
Elizabeth's love of color
and pattern grew, lingered
and is a fixture today
of all of her works.
After returning to the US< Elizabeth
attended Rhode Island School
of Design and graduated in 2006.
Her picture book, the Boy
Who Harnessed the Wind,
Dial Books was an Amazon Best
Books for Children in 2012
and received other awards.
Elizabeth now lives in Albany where
she explores a multi-cultural world
through painting, beading, sewing,
collage and fine art painting
from her own imagination and
in published children book
where she brings to
life other stories.
Her ninth illustrated children's
book is the Legendary Ms. Lena
Horne, which is from
Simon and Schuster
and will publish next year in 2017.
And last, but certainly not least
my good friend Rene Colato Lainez.
He is an award winning
Salvadoran author
of many multi-cultural books
including Vamanos, Let's Go.
The Tooth Fairy Meets El Maton
Perez and From North to South.
He's a graduate of the Vermont
College MFA Program in writing
for children and young adults.
Rene is a bilingual
elementary school teacher
at Fernandalez Elementary School
where the students know him
as the teacher full of stories.
His goal as an author is to produce
good multi-cultural literature,
stories where minority children
are portrayed in a positive way,
where they can see themselves as
heroes and where they can dream
and have hopes for their future.
He wants to write authentic stories
of Latin American children
living in the United States.
Will you please help me welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Meg Medina: So the first
question I have is really just sort
of place us because immigration is
in fact, a continuum from a person
who has arrived yesterday,
to a person whose family
has been here for some time.
So Rene, can we start with you.
Can you just sort of place us
where you are from originally
and where you fall in
the immigrant continuum.
>> Rene Colato Lainez: I was
born in El Salvador and due
to the Civil War my father and
I had to leave the country.
My mother was already
here in the United States.
And I remember that we
leave in early morning.
I had brand new shoes and I
loved those shoes so much.
And through the journey
those new shoes became worn
and filled with holes everywhere.
It was a trip of three months from
El Salvador to the United States.
So, I had been in every single
state of the immigrant experience,
first as an undocumented
immigrant, then later I was able
to get a work permit
to start working.
Then my mom qualified
for the amnesty program,
so she became a resident and
she applied for my residence.
And finally I became a USA
citizen; so I have been everywhere.
I'm happy to be here.
>> Elizabeth Zunon: I was actually
born here in the United States.
My mother's family has been
here for many, many years.
My father came here from the
Ivory Coast in the 70's to study
at the State University
in New York in Albany,
and that's where they met.
So, growing up in the Ivory Coast,
we lived there until
I was almost 13.
I did most of my schooling
there but we came back
to the Albany area almost every
summer to visit my grandparents.
So, I feel like no matter
what country I was in,
I was always looked at as the other.
When I was living in
the Ivory Coast,
which is a French speaking country,
many of the kids referred to me
as le melikel (ph) and when I came
here sometimes the kids would refer
to me as "oh that girl from Africa".
So I was called -- always had one
foot in two different cultures
and kind of always in between,
but I've been here full time
for almost 19 years now,
so I consider myself a
bi-racial African American.
>> Wendy Shang: Hi I'm Wendy Shang.
I was also born in the United
States, my mom is right there.
[ Applause ]
>> Wendy Shang: My parents
came here in the late 1950's,
early 1960's to study and by the
time I was born they were already
American citizens.
But I would say that even under
kind of rather ideal circumstances
for coming here that you know
there is still that dual identity.
And also I grew up in Northern
Virginia, and we live there now
and I tell my kids I was the only
Asian kid in my elementary school.
And they really cannot
conceive of that now.
And I was told them like I remember
the second Asian kid that showed up.
>> Aisha Saeed: So I'm
Pakistani American.
I was born in Miami, Florida.
But my father immigrated to the
United States in the 1960's as well
and he was an electrical
engineer there.
When he came here he found out
that even though he had that degree
and experience he kind of
needed to start over here.
So, he started off
working I think Jersey subs
and working his way back up.
Went to school and
got another degree
and became an engineer
again here in the US.
And even though I was
born and raised here,
I was telling Meg earlier, I felt
like I didn't maybe go to Pakistan
that much, but Pakistan came to me
because all of our friends growing
up were Pakistani American, like me.
All of my relatives over the
years from the time I was
about 18 months old, slowly
began immigrating to the US.
And our home was the doorstep
that they always arrived at.
And so all the way
until I was pretty much
in college I always was having
people from Pakistan coming
and immigrating in and coming
through our home in
order to settle down.
So, yeah, that's my story.
>> Meg Medina: So what are some
of the topics that you think
of as very culturally
specific to your group?
That find their way into your work?
So, for example I often
look at strong women
in my work, Machismo in my work.
Lack of language and those kind of
things; what do you pull from inside
of your cultural experience
to put in your books?
And any one of you can answer.
>> Rene Colato Lainez:
For me it's equality
because even though we
are different corridors,
we speak different languages,
at the end we are all
children of plant earth.
So, in my book I see equality, if we
can say in English we can also sing
in Spanish to same song and
we can have fun together.
We have heroes, Latina
heroes, American heroes.
My idea is why to fight for,
because I am different from you?
Together we can have fun and
we can have double the fun,
double the culture.
And also in my work you can
see the immigrant child,
especially the child that is
insecure, the child who has been
for the future, but at that point he
has a problem related with culture
or with immigration and
he wants to continue.
He wants to succeed so I'm
telling him, "Yes you can do it.
It happened to me, I know it
is happening to you right now.
But there is always a light
at the end of the tunnel",
so that's the main focus on my work.
>> Aisha Saeed: I think for
me growing up I loved to read.
I started reading when I
think I was three years old.
I just loved to read, but I never
saw myself in books and I never knew
that I wasn't seeing myself
in books because I didn't know
that I should be in the books.
And so I think it wasn't until
college that I actually read a book
where there was somebody
from my culture represented.
And so -- and that was a very,
very moving experience for me
to see a cover, Shabanu,
Daughter of the Wind.
And I remember just reading
it and it had nothing to do
with my life or upbringing.
But there was so much I saw of
myself in that book anyways.
And so when I write books, because
of that life long experience I have,
I -- it's very important to me
that my stories reflect
Pakistani Americans.
They're not generalized, everyone
has a different experience
but I did, definitely my upbringing
and my culture and my book --
my book is about a girl who
is forced into a marriage.
I was not, but a lot of
the cultural aspects in it,
like how her parents were just
very nervous about she related
to western society and how much
they wanted her to stay a part
of their culture, all of
that I put in my book.
And it's been very gratifying to
hear from other South Asian children
and other Muslim kids who read the
book and said, "Yeah that's me"
because I never had that.
And so for me that's a very
important part of writing
for young people is to give
them that mirror in the book
that reflects their own experiences.
>> Wendy Shang: I was going to say
I think from my book and it was
about the sense that you are
representing if you are not
of many people, what you do is
you are representing everyone.
I remember my dad always telling me
"What you do represents our family
and represents our
people", pressure.
And--
>> Meg Medina: I know that horror.
>> Wendy Shang: I think in my
second book The Way Home Looks Now,
there was that sensibility of
wanting to maintain that facade
of everything is oak from the fire
even though things were not okay.
>> Aisha Saeed: I think Wendy just
touched on such an important point
when writing about your
culture there are bad parts
about your culture too.
Like there's the forced marriage
in my book and that is a challenge.
When you want to reflect a mirror
but you're also sometimes putting
a mirror onto things that --
and you don't want to do that.
You don't want to be the one that
puts that bad thing out there,
but it also needs to
be talked about too.
>> Meg Medina: I was
thinking about that earlier
because I was thinking also
sometimes you write in North
to South for example you're writing
about a mom who is deported, right?
And you're writing about a forced
marriage and so are there moments --
and then I'm going to get
back to other question.
We knew this would happen.
So what do we do collectively?
There are moments when you're
writing about something
that you know is going to set
somebody's hair on fire, right?
Or you're going to receive
heavy criticism for it or does
that ever creep into you like
do you ever say "I don't want
to say that" or what do you think?
Like when you're writing
about undocumented children
or undocumented parents?
>> Rene Colato Lainez: Yes for
example my shoes and I is a story
of me crossing three borders from
El Salvador to the United States.
And since I was writing it, I
knew I could see people talking,
this book is about
illegal immigration.
Someone crossing a river,
but I wrote it that --
and I knew that it
would be a hard book.
At the same time, the same year
From North to South was published
and this book is about mom,
who is deported to Mexico
because she doesn't have the right
papers to live in the United States.
And I remember our reviewer, the
same person review the two books
and one said this book is excellent
because we are deporting
people who are illegal.
And this book is terrible because
someone is crossing the border
and it is written by
the same author.
So, I said that before, I'm
talking about it, but my focus is
for those -- so we can hear
there are many different ways
to immigrate.
And I think children and
the population is to hear
that the different voices.
And one voice is as
important as the other.
>> Meg Medina: And so there
are those hard corners,
and then there are these
beautiful corners as well.
And it brings me to Liz's work
and also to Wendy's because I --
in the books that you illustrate
Liz you're often working
on heroes of other cultures.
The Boy Who Could Harness the Wind,
if you could talk a little bit
about that book, and
also one plastic bag.
And Wendy the history and the
heroes associated with Taiwan.
And so Liz you first,
tell us about that --
about the process of writing,
introducing the heroes
of one culture to children here.
>> Elizabeth Zunon: Well as
the illustrator I'm tasked
with visually depicting the
characters for an American audience.
And in the case of the Boy
who Harnessed the Wind,
it's a story about a young
boy who is 14 years old
in Malawi in East Africa.
And he lives in a farming
community and there happens
to be a very bad drought
that particular year and all
of his families crops, corn
and tobacco crops died.
And they are not able to earn
any money for him to keep going
to school, so he has to drop
out of school and he ends
up finding a library down the road
that has a lot of science books.
He finds a science book called
"Using Energy" and he figures
out from the pictures in this
book how to build a windmill.
So he goes to the local junk
yard, he takes all these pieces
of scrap metal, lumber and he
finds a tire from a bicycle
and an old light bulb and
all these scraps of things.
And he brings them home and he
kind of cobbles them together
and makes an actual
working windmill.
And when I was tasked with
illustrating this book,
I thought okay I've
never been to Malawi.
I've never been to East Africa.
He lives in a very different
country than my experience
in the Ivory Coast,
the Ivory Coast --
the city that I lived
in is very cosmopolitan.
You know I didn't spent a lot
of time in the countryside,
I didn't know any farmers.
So, I figured what about his
life can I kind of appropriate,
and kind of use in my process
of creating the illustrations.
So, his process of
going to the junk yard
and collecting all these different
pieces of things reminded me
of my process of collage, which
is how I create the illustrations
for the books.
I use oil paint to paint the
faces and the skies and the ground
and then a lot of the fabric
that people are wearing
for their clothing, houses,
trees and things like that I use
by taking colorful paper and
fabric that I've collected
that has different
patterns and things on it.
And I cut them out and I glue
them to create one piece of art;
so that's one way that I
kind of associated myself
with William's experience
even though I,
my life was nothing like his.
>> Meg Medina: And
he's real, William --
I mean this actually happened.
And the Plastic Bag is the
same sort of heroic simple,
the heroic and the ordinary person.
I found that so empowering.
>> Elizabeth Zunon: Yeah One
Plastic Bag, the recycling women
of the Gambia, West Africa
was an opportunity for me
to illustrate a story about a
crafter, and that's another thing
that I do when I'm not illustrating
books is I make jewelry and purses
and I sell them at
local craft fairs.
So, it was a way for me to identify
with this woman Isatou Ceesay,
in this story who lives in a
small village where there's a lot
of plastic bag trash
floating around.
And I thought the feeling that
she must get from making something
with her bare hands and then going
out and sharing it with the public
and hoping that somebody
likes it enough to buy it,
is a feeling that I have
too when I go to craft fairs
and I have a table full of my
things and I'm hoping okay,
I hope I can make my money
back from this today.
So those are little things that I
pick out of these characters lives
that I can associate with
myself, either with the process
of illustrating the book by
collecting different things,
or the feelings that they
must go through in the books.
>> Meg Medina: Wendy I'm going
to talk to you about humor.
And also Rene I'm going to throw
you under the bus for this one too
because you're both
really funny people.
And if you would talk a little bit
-- I remember laughing out loud,
certain the Way Home Looks
Now is not a comic novel,
but the Great Wall of Lucy Wu was.
I remember laughing
out loud several times
and your main characters
relationship.
And also Rene in the Big
Mish mash of what happens
when the Tooth fairy meets
Raton Perez and so on.
So Wendy, why don't
we start with you.
How do you go about
grabbing humor and how --
especially as it relates to
you know, against the back drop
of Chinese American culture?
>> Wendy Shang: Yeah I find
the mechanics of writing humor,
dying is easy, comedy is hard.
And I think just generally is
to not aim straight for it,
but to write the scene and
then find the funny in it.
And then start pulling it out.
For example in the Great Wall of
Lucy Wu, Lucy finds out that she has
to give up basketball to go to
Chinese school, and she is furious.
And so that's the first
layer is "I'm really mad".
And then you know second, third
pass it's like she's going
to write a song about this.
And so she has a protest song
that she sings [Inaudible]
Chinese school is not for me.
[ Laughter ]
>> Wendy Shang: And
you know it's just --
humor is always finding the
unexpected connection between things
and I think especially
multi-cultural literature that's
so important is to find out that the
person you thought you had nothing
in common with is some --
has something that you
both can be joyous about.
>> Meg Medina: And
how about in your work
because I think it's
hilarious do you know,
tell them about who Raton
Perez is, they may not know?
>> Rene Colato Lainez: Raton
Perez is a tooth collector
from Latin America.
>> Meg Medina: Did you know?
>> Rene Colato Lainez: In El
Salvador I grew up with the idea
of Raton Perez and when I came to
the United States they talk to me
about a tooth fairy
and I was confused.
Who is the tooth fairy?
For me at that point a
tooth fairy was the one
from Cinderella and Sleeping Beauty.
And I couldn't believe that fairy
collecting tooth from children.
So my story is about [Inaudible] and
of course because he speaks English
and Spanish, Raton said
this is a new one for me
and it took [Inaudible], but at
the same time the tooth fairy said
"This is my territory".
In that book is confrontation of
mine, mine, mine, mine, me, me,
me to see who will get it.
And I think I use my teachers
voice because I teach kindergarten
and the children say the
funny teacher, he's funny.
>> Meg Medina: He is
funny, they're right.
So you do this mish mash
and you bring up also
that you are a teacher, and so as
I was thinking about my own work
and your work collectively
like in your dream,
in your mind how do
you want educators
to use your book with young people?
If you could prescribe
this for them,
like please use this book this way.
For example I will
often tell teachers,
please don't have them do vocabulary
list and answer questions at the end
of the chapter, I'll be really
mad at you if you do that.
How -- and let's start with
Aisha, how would you want Written
in the Stars used in a
classroom with students?
>> Aisha Saeed: That's
a good question.
I think no vocabulary tests.
Then they will hate my book.
But one way that I saw --
I just actually as going to
do a school visit and I walked
in on a teacher and what they
had done was they took my book
and they took American Born
Chinese and so they were looking
at the similarities between
the books and the differences.
And I had not actually read
his book at that point.
I had it but I hadn't read it;
so I went home and read it.
And it's a graphic novel,
it's completely different.
It has nothing to do with my book,
but I loved that they took
two totally different books
and were researching what they
have in common, what they don't.
I really would love for teachers
to use it as a way to look
at the specific aspects of Pakistan
that are covered in the book,
but also take from there
what are the things we share
in common just universally
with the themes in this book?
For example parents
to exert pressure,
not just Pakistani parents.
All parents and children have that
yin yang of I want to do this,
and no you can't do that and when
is that too much, when is that okay.
I think there's a lot of themes
in the book that are specific,
but that can be related to and so
I think I would love to see it used
as a way to learn about Pakistan,
but also to highlight how
are we the same as well?
>> Wendy Shang: My mind went
in to two totally opposite
directions with that question.
I mean on one hand, I would
just like my book to be used
like any other book that
gets to go in the classroom.
And sometimes you get in the
danger of being pigeon holed.
I have a friend whose children go
to immersion school in San Francisco
and she sent me the reading
list and both of my books are
on there; that never happens.
But I would love you
know, for classrooms
that don't necessarily have
Chinese American students
in them to be open to the book.
Boy book, girl book, who
is interested in this book?
I would hope that it would
be opened up to that.
And then the other direction
my mind went was in both
of my books there are adults
who don't always say
what they are thinking.
But as a writer I know
what they're thinking
and I know why they
did what they did.
And I think it would be
really cool for teachers
to invite their students
to rewrite a scene
from the other characters
perspective and as a way of learning
to see that sometimes people
behave in a certain way
and that they might have
a completely different set
of motivations than what you
are initially tempted to think.
>> Meg Medina: Fascinating.
>> Elizabeth Zunon: I like
the idea of using my books
as a jumping off point for
other creative projects.
For example one plastic bag is about
women who use strips of plastic bags
to crochet little change purses.
So I do a lot of schools
where I bring all these strips
of colorful plastic bags,
and I'll bring plastic,
empty plastic yogurt cups or
other cardboard or plastic items
and we'll have like "What can
you invent with these things"?
"What can you create"?
"What kind of fashion accessories
can you make with these"?
With the boy who harnessed
the wind, I like to you know,
put in some science, technology,
engineering and math in there.
Like if you could create any
invention that would solve a problem
in the world, what would it be?
And I like to ask different groups
of especially elementary school
students to identify a problem
in their community and then sit
down and draw a thing that could fix
or help that problem, or make
a machine that would solve
that problem using found objects.
>> Meg Medina: That sounds to me
like a really empowering thing.
You know to take an example of what
William did in his life and sort
of apply it to your own,
and how about you Rene?
>> Rene Colato Lainez: Yeah for
me is for children and teachers
to open new doors, new windows,
new horizons to discover new ways,
new games that [Inaudible]
and it always nice
to see all the children
playing Mexican Bingo.
And even though all the pictures are
in Spanish, I can see the big smiles
at the same time, looking
at the picture.
And that is culture for them, so --
and also for the tooth
fairy of Raton Perez,
at the end of the book children
say "Oh for my next one I would
like the little mouse
to come to my house".
And that is great for me because
a book they discover a new hero
or a new game, a new song.
>> Meg Medina: I also like
-- we were talking earlier,
we sat outside in the sunshine.
We got here a little early
and you know Rene's books come
out in bilingual format often.
And my books come out
in English editions
and Spanish editions,
right, they're separate.
Some of its design and
we talked about the pros
and cons of that as well.
Because sometimes the role of books
for families that are multi-lingual.
Where grandparents don't
speak the same language
as the parents, as the children.
And so for me I feel a certain
urgency around making sure
that we have editions either
bilingual or dual language
so that families can rally around
story, that names their experience
but in the languages that
they're most comfortable with.
And then I wanted to ask you
also sort of a difficult question
because certainly children are
not immune to what they see
on television, what they're hearing
in the news and the conversations
that are coming from the
lips of adults in the world.
And so I'm -- I guess the question
I have for maybe Aisha, Rene,
really anybody who -- what is the
role of books right now when we have
so many really ugly
characterizations
of immigrant children
or immigrant families?
So, I'm asking this
question because I know Aisha
for example you're
raising three sons.
And what do you say?
You and I have talked about
this, you've expressed this
like there are moments of injury
and you've probably seen this
with your students where people
say really painful, awful things.
What is the role of our
work to address that?
Is there a role?
>> Aisha Saeed: I think one
thing for me personally as a mom,
my oldest son he just started --
he's ending kindergarten
actually next week.
But his first week of kindergarten
I had to pull him out just
after one week because
every single day
from the first day he was bullied,
called racial slurs, religious slurs
by other fellow five year
olds and shoved to the ground.
And I had to withdraw him and
take him to a safer place.
And he is in a safer place
and he's thrived there.
But you know the things that he was
saying, the children were saying,
the things that he came
home like started asking me
"How can I get lighter",
"Why is my skin this color"?
All these questions, you know
somebody taught them that.
And I just feel like now more
than ever the role of teachers
and librarians and others that
come in contact with children
who are getting these messages
is to counter those messages
and the most powerful
way is through a book.
And through you know, through
reading a book about another child
who they can suddenly relate to.
Even though back home their parents
are teaching them certain things
and there are certain news stations
on telling them certain
things in the background.
They can read a book and say "Wait".
And so they may never
meet somebody like that
but that prejudice could
possibly be affected.
And that's actually one of the
reasons that I started thinking
about writing picture books
sometime in the future just
because it is a very, very serious
issue and it's not just my son.
It's happening -- the percentages
in California, they did a study
and I think it was
75% of Muslim teens
in high school have reported
bullying or harassment.
75%. So it's a really big issue,
and I mean books alone can't do it
but I do think that they are a
powerful resource that gatekeepers,
librarians, teacher
can get in the hands
of children can potentially
make a difference.
>> Rene Colato Lainez: Yeah
for example my student,
their parents speak Spanish and
they are trying to speak English
and for many Spanish is not enough,
Spanish is not good,
Spanish is not cool.
They have to speak English because
everyone are speaking in English.
So I think -- I am writing books to
tell those children Spanish is good.
You can speak English,
you can speak Spanish.
You can play games in
English; you can play games
in Spanish; so that's my main goal.
That's why I am writing
about equality.
You can have tooth fairy
of course, was wonderful
but also you can Raton Perez.
And also let's play football,
football can mean soccer in Spanish
and you can play football which
is Amirian football in Spanish
and even though football
is something,
they are two different games and
you can have fun in both of them.
>> Meg Medina: Can you
tell them a little bit
about my mother's an alien.
This one cracked me up.
I look at the cover
and I said oh it's sort
of a science fiction
story, what a new thing.
And then Rene said to me "no".
Tell them --
>> Rene Colato Lainez:
That book is about Sophia
and she has discovered a big secret.
By accident she found out
a little card, mamas card
and mamas picture is in there
and also the word alien.
So she believed that
her mother is an alien.
>> Meg Medina: You got to love it.
You can't make this stuff up.
>> Rene Colato Lainez: When Sophia
asked "Mama is this really you;
is this a real card" and
Mama say "Of course it is.
I always wanted this card.
The day that I received this
card it was a wonderful day".
So Sophia now she really
believed that mom is an alien.
And this is my new book
coming out in July.
>> Meg Medina: And I think we are
almost, okay I have one minute
so I'm going to put this in.
And so some of us publish
with large presses,
and some with small presses, right?
And so -- and for those of
you that don't' know Simon
and Schuster announced this year
Salam Reeds which is a new imprint
that deals with Muslim literature,
Muslim characters and so on;
so that seemed to me so
hopeful when I saw it
and we have Cinco Punto press.
We have places that we go to,
but can you talk a little
bit about your experiences?
Large press, small press, which has
been -- how has that worked for you?
Wendy I know that you
publish in a big --
>> Wendy Shang: Yeah
I'm with Scholastic.
>> Meg Medina: That's
as big as it gets.
>> Wendy Shang: It is and
when I first saw it I was
like I don't have anything
to say about small presses.
And then the last week I had the
pleasure of -- Kathy Crutcher.
Is Kathy Crutcher here?
There's a woman who developed
a model where she partners
with local non-profits and
encourages kids to write
and publish their own stories
and they're beautifully done.
Nice everything and
they're fantastic looking.
And then I was made aware
of the [Inaudible] has a
diverse minds book contest
where they encourage young people
to write stories incorporating
diversity.
There is like a $5,000 first prize
and their stories get published.
So, I'm not in it but I can
definitely see where it's coming
from and I'm supporting
them as best I can.
>> Meg Medina; Last thoughts?
Okay I see the microphone coming
around, so here's the deal.
If you have a question you
have to wait for the microphone
because you're being
recorded, no pressure.
You're being recorded and
I really encourage you
to ask these wonderful people
anything that's on you reminds.
So, questions?
Great. In the back.
Hold on for the microphone.
>> Hi, it's almost nice to
be here at this program.
But I have a couple questions,
first I'm a retired school librarian
so I'm always glad to meet authors.
I'm also on the board
of the children's [Inaudible]
book awards program,
children's illustrators.
My question is mainly for Aisha or
anybody else who wants to answer.
I really liked your comment where
you said that as you were growing
up you didn't know that you
should see yourself in books,
so you didn't really miss it.
And another comment you mentioned
that you want your book treated
like any other books, well I grew
up in Washington D.C. and like you,
I didn't really see myself in books.
But it was okay, right?
And I think sometimes
those who don't know,
they say those poor
deprived children.
How did they manage?
But the question then, and
it's for you or anybody else,
how can we explain to people
that even though we didn't grow
up seeing ourselves, and
on another note I do want
to say there actually
were books written.
For instance here in
Washington you can go
to Morlan's [Inaudible] Research
Center and just see books written
about African Americans from
beginning of time almost,
go to Alexandria and
Egypt but anyway,
the point is for the most part we
didn't see ourselves accurately.
That's the other piece because
we might have seen the Tarzan,
the sambos and so on.
But I guess it didn't
mean that much to us,
or you know we weren't
astute enough to be offended.
So --
>> Meg Medina: Well that's
changed; I'm here to tell you.
>> Exactly, but I have to
say this, I was in a museum,
a school museum right in
Arlington a couple years ago
where they had a classroom set
up and they had some old books,
slid into the little wooden desks.
And there actually was a little
black sambo book in there and I had
to bring it to the attention
of the director there.
But how do we explain to people the
history of how this has all evolved?
>> Aisha Saeed: I mean
for me personally just
because I didn't see
myself in a book,
and as a seven year old
wasn't bothered by it,
doesn't mean that it
wasn't a problem.
And I think just because I
didn't' see myself in a book,
I still felt like the
other because of that.
I just didn't know how to articulate
it as a child or as a teenager.
But I did, when I would write my own
stories, because I loved to write,
I never wrote about
Pakistani Americas ever
or Muslims because I never saw it.
Like I said it was only until
college when I saw that book
and I then I started talking.
I was a book seller briefly and
I talked to other book sellers
and they were like "No you should
write your stories if you want to"
and then I started doing it.
So I think yeah, I mean I didn't
miss it because I didn't know
that I was -- I could have it.
But I think I did --
I was deprived for it.
My children do not have that
because there's Salam Reeds
and there's all these like --
and people are taking
chances on books now
that they weren't back then.
And there are more
books being published.
And I see my son, he
sees Kalmalah Hahn,
Ms. Marvel she's a Pakistani
American teenager and when I saw
that first edition I cried.
My son was like "Okay
cool", that's neat.
Because he has a library,
there's not enough in there,
there should be more but he
has much more than I ever did.
And so I think I see, I
see how it matters to him.
I see how it helps him
feel like he belongs;
so yeah when people say it didn't
bother you then, it should have.
I just didn't know
better like you said.
>> Wendy Shang: I wonder
if it's the right question
to ask, were you harmed?
And maybe a better question
is what more could you do
if you saw yourself in books?
And you know how much more of
your potential could you reach
if you saw yourself as the hero in
the story and every other place?
>> If ever there was a year
that proved post-racial society is
nowhere close it would be this year.
But I'm doing exit interviews
with students right now
and for the first time ever
I'm asking them to identify --
I always ask for demographics.
Please give me your
race or ethnicity.
This year quite a number of them
are calling themselves Americans
and it does have me thinking,
what does a post-racial society
actually look like for the young?
And how long do you think it's
going to take us to get there?
>> Meg Medina: I'm so
glad I'm the moderator.
What do you think guys.
>> Wendy Shang: You
know you meet people
and it's like I don't see race.
>> Meg Medina: But they do.
>> Wendy Shang: First of all
that's a very privileged thing
to be able to say.
Because that means -- whether
or not you choose to see people,
doesn't affect how
other people get seen.
And I think we're kind
of reaching --
we see, let's talk about
it and you want a timeline?
>> Meg Medina: I think the big lapse
also is what's really difficult
of course when you have
conversations that deal
with people's perceptions in
books, around race and so on.
Is that any conversation
surrounding race
in the United States
is a very delicate one.
And it comes against a really
complicated and painful context.
And so everyone gets worked up.
It is hard on both ends.
It's hard to be on the receiving
end of something and pointed out
and have people say
"That's not what I meant.
I didn't mean to injure you.
I'm not racist", but
those kinds of things.
It's a hard conversation and
I find myself sometimes moving
through the world with like
this little invisible plaque
over my head, "I come in peace".
that's really what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to make people feel
comfortable at the same time
that I'm telling them the
truth of what's happening.
I also -- I looked at my
World Book Encyclopedia Child,
remember those, if you're old.
You remember, I had a set of
those and my favorite was volume 9
and anyway I looked through
it recently because I have it
and there's not a single child
of color, any color on the pages.
And it was my favorite
book and I wasn't there.
I don't know what it's
going to look like.
I think that right now sometimes
I worry that when people dive into
"I'm American, I don't see color".
I think that is a very
telling statement,
and a worrisome statement.
Because if your eyes work
you do, in fact see color.
You do in fact see
what people look like.
The real question is what do you see
here and here in your heart in terms
of how you interpret and embrace.
>> I have a question for you guys.
Okay reviews have started
naming race
in their reviews, have
you seen them?
>> Aisha Saeed: I saw
one and I was so --
I sat there and just stared at it.
I was like "Wait, what"?
[ Cross talking ]
>> So I actually read one of the
reviews and it went out of its way
to call out the White characters.
The White character,
the white character.
I started laughing really hard
because I was so unused to it.
What do you guys think
about that now?
>> Aisha Saeed: I was like
you, I started laughing.
So I need to process
it a little bit more.
I think it's great because it is --
that's my initial reaction,
that it's great.
If you feel the need to point
out in the story about basketball
that the main character is -- the
whole story is all about basketball,
you need to point out that the
main character is a certain race,
other than White.
Then why not point out
that they are White?
I think fair is fair,
but like you it really --
it made me laugh and it stayed
with me and that's kind of telling
that it stayed with me so much,
just for the fact that they named
who the main character
was, it was interesting.
>> Elizabeth Zunon: I have a
little anecdote to do with that.
My mother is White, my father
is Black and when I was applying
to college I refused to check
only one box and I refused
to check the other box for race.
So I always checked white and
the box for the white and black.
And I got into school
and the -- after my --
the end of my junior
year in college I needed
to find a new work study
job so I applied to work
at the multi-cultural
affairs office at my college.
And when I showed up there they
said "Well we've never heard of you,
how long have you been
at this school"?
I said "I've been at this
school for three years,
I'm about to be a senior".
And so they looked in their
paperwork, because they had a list
of all of the students of
color attending the school.
And when they found my name they saw
that next to my name it said "White"
and they all started to laugh.
Like "ha, ha, ha Liz,
we've never heard of you
because you've been
White for three years
and you're just showing
up here now".
And then I thought yeah
it's funny because according
to the school I am
white, but if you look
at me maybe you don't see white.
As far as my DNA I'm equally
white than I am black.
So should we be laughing at the
fact that "Oh Liz is white".
It was a very weird feeling.
>> Rene Colato Lainez: Yeah many
people think that I am Filipino
and one time I was speaking
with this person in English
and finally I started
talking in Spanish
and he said hable es Spanish?
I thought you were
from the Philippines.
And that's Latino, we have
all the colors of the world.
>> Meg Medina: That's the biggest
misconception of Latino culture
because we come across every race.
>> Hi, Roxanna with First
Book and I just want
to say what a pleasure it is
to actually use your books
for family engagement opportunities.
It's one of the things
that educators
from our networks say all
the time that you know how
to actually use a book in a
way that it brings conversation
that is extended from the
classroom into the home.
And I know for a fact that
your books have done that,
so just really wanted to
say thank you for your work.
>> Yes. Hi thank you, it's
been a wonderful conversation.
I am also with the schools, with
family and community engagement
and the experience with many
programs and always looking
for books that bring
interesting perspectives on race
and culture and gender as well.
And what I find myself
sometimes struggling
and a little bit turned off and now
I'm more hesitant is there seems
to be a tendency among writers
of those books to choose topics
that are real topics,
like poverty or racism
or even historical situations in
the past in which I have found
when you read them to kids, I find
myself torn a little problematic
because they are in a
sense kids that define
with those characters,
they are embarrassed.
For example you have a book
with something about Mexico,
just inventing something here.
And then you see all the little
Mexican kids without shoes
and you know really ugly looking
parents who are very poor,
or things like that and it's a real
kind of embarrassment for them.
Or the same when you
deal with certain issues
about slavery and things like that.
So I'm curious about
your thoughts about that.
Because I'm always looking for books
that affirm kids and especially
when they are in elementary
school, I think with middle school,
high school is a different thing
because we can have
more deep conversations
about races, inequality, injustice.
And I do go there with
elementary kids,
it's not that I'm avoiding the
topic, but I am trying to look
for those other books that
you know create a sense
of empowerment of kids and hope.
So I'm curious to hear your thoughts
and if you have struggled with that
when you choose your
topics for your stories
and what's your reaction to that?
>> Rene Colato Lainez: Yeah
for me it's to be authentic.
When I am writing a story I focus on
the positive in the authentic way.
Because if I want to talk about
Mexican I don't have to talk
about their sombreros or
singing and eating tacos.
There are many wonderful
things to talk about Mexico.
And also in my country El
Salvador, so I go for the positive.
I see that the positive and the
authentic is the most powerful thing
to talk about for children to
love their culture and language.
>> Meg Medina: And also where
you're picking the books.
So you know Los Americas award
winners, [Inaudible] Asian Pacific,
literature winners, I think
you want the best examples
because when books are selected
for those lists sometimes I
think those questions come up.
Does this book authentically
portray the experience
but also respectfully
portray the experience?
I write about folks often families
who are from moderate to low income,
but I think respectfully and in a
way that doesn't show them as broken
or excessive suffering and so on.
I think it's developing a pallet
for where you're searching
for those books.
And I'm always encourage when people
are looking for them and I ask you
to continue to ask your
librarians and your book sellers.
Exert that sort of pressure; I
don't know if you feel that way.
Your request of that material and
your conversation at that level
with your local librarian
is important, it's essential
because it raises their
awareness and cues them
into the developing conversation.
Because the conversation is
getting more interesting,
it is getting more sophisticated.
We are not just thankful
that anything is published.
We're really holding things
to higher standards now.
I was going to say I
think that's the --
>> If there's one last question.
>> I was waiting, which I don't
do very well, so this is good.
A question and again more
of a comment and gratitude.
Having worked with a large
diversity population from homogenous
to elite private school and
now I'm at a large urban school
in Northern Virginia, probably
one of the most diverse
in Northern Virginia
if not in the country
and having a large
number of immigrants.
Read aside and students not reading
for pleasure is a whole other
panel we could spend several days
discussing that.
But getting books in their
hands that make sense.
Students have lost the
ability to hear their own voice
or to hear other voices in books
and they don't know what those sound
like and with those varying
characters look like,
we have to teach that.
And so when a student picks
up a book and they can read
about a character that's like
them and like their background,
it's critical to engaging them.
So keep doing what you're
doing and thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.